hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the US Chess Championship we
know who the winner is as Fabby won the
event one full round before the
tournament ended but this is the game um
you guys requested from the final round
and also I believe I have solved my
audio issues with the previous
microphone I I tried a different one and
now there doesn't seem to be any humming
so I don't know what what it was it just
appeared out of nowhere and well uh
hopefully I have fixed it now but just
in case if you still hear any any
humming or buzzing do mention it in the
comment section so there you have it
world's youngest Grand Master abanu
Mishra with the white pieces taking on
the The Legend leevon Aran let's check
it out we have D4 Knight to F6 Pawn to
C4 G6 uh leevon going for the Kings
Indian defense and G3 Bishop to G7 we
have Bishop to G2 and Castles by leavon
Knight to C3 Knight to C6 and now Pawn
to E3 so a bit of a uh different
approach than you usually have against
the Kings Indian defense butth okay Pawn
to D6 we have Knight G to E2 and pawn to
E5 now white will of course advance to
D5 attacking the Knight Knight to E7 and
pawn to B3 usually you will have um a
very rapid development against the King
zinder on the queen side with B4 coming
but here as leavon is also slow playing
on the on the king side abanu decides to
slow play it on the queen side we have
Knight to D7 here there are some games
where H5 and Bishop to F5 were played
but Leon plays Knight F to D7 and it is
now uh as of move nine that we have a
completely new game he wants to play
Ponto F5 as one usually does um in the
king's Indian defense so Bishop to B2
and pawn to F5 we have Pawn to F4 abanu
invites leevon to advance the pawn all
the way to E4 H and he does and now
Knight to D4 so okay Knight to E6 is the
threat to Fork the queen and the Rook
you have to deal with that we have
Knight to F6 now the bishop covers the
E6 and uh here abanu castles we have
Pawn to C5 attacking the Knight and D
captures on C6 aasa we have B captures
and now Queen to D2 and while you really
want to kick away this Knight with C5 uh
you do not want to allow Knight to B5
because this Pawn will just become
really really weak and even if you
advance it to D5 white white will throw
in a rook F to D1 and just put pressure
on that D4 Pawn you're going to have to
defend it then for example Knight to A4
puts pressure on C5 D5 is weak so not
maybe the best way to handle things so
leavon first place A6 takes away the B5
Square from the Knight on D4 and the
Knight on C3 of course and Rook F to D1
we have Queen to C7 and now Knight D to
e sorry not Knight C to E2 Knight D to
E2 uh Rook to d8 nicely aligning The
Rook with the queen and here comes uh
Pawn to C5 not a move you'd expect as
Rook to d8 was played but the Rook on d8
is only defended by the queen so of
course abanu uh leavon cannot capture on
C5 we have Knight to E8 and abanu goes
Knight to A4 now going for Knight to B6
to put pressure on on Black's Queen side
even further but also to support the C5
Pawn B B4 is coming and so on and also
offering a trade of dark Square Bishops
so L on trades we have Bishop captures
Queen captures now abanu grabs hold of
this long diagonal and now uh you while
you could play D5 it's maybe allowing
white a bit too much now is coming to B6
the other Knight is coming to D4 uh
doesn't look all that impressive uh you
might not lose but it doesn't look like
you're you know anywhere near even
attempting to win this game so leavon
went for Knight to D5 it's the the
objectively the best idea going after
the E3 Pawn abanu defends it and now
Knight E to F6 now this KN is coming to
G4 to put even more pressure on E3
Knight to D4 uh and now we have Knight
to G4 and look at this Knight to uh
Knight to B6 attacking the rook and a
that's undefended and here you have to
uh decide what to play it's not an easy
decision because uh well you obviously
have to take the Knight and you kind of
don't want to but you have if you go for
something like Knight captures on E3
which is a move you're of course looking
at then Knight captures on A8 okay you
might even be willing to sacrifice the
exchange for this massive Center the
problem is after the queen moves and
goes after the Knight there's also
Knight capter and C6 attacking the queen
and the rook and now you run into uh you
run into trouble here so instead after
Knight B6 of course you have to capture
Knight captures on B6 was played C
captures and now Queen captures on B6
and here uh Pawn to H3 AB Manu says all
right uh get get uh rid of the knight
from G4 I don't like it attacking my E3
pawn and if this was the position you
were presented with and it is as I am
presenting it to you what would you play
here even feel free to pause the video
video and you know try to uh figure out
a best way for black to continue this
position while I give you a couple of
[Music]
seconds so uh for those of you who were
able to do it congratulations on well
it's not really a position that you have
to Solo or you know to win the game it's
it's just you know a question how would
you continue here so for those of you
who found C5 congratulations that's a
great move for those of you who found
Knight captures on E3
again congratulations that's also a nice
move and for those of you who went back
with the Knight Knight to F6 uh that's
also a nice move it's actually the one
leevon played but it's a very passive
one as you'll see in the game so he
played Knight back to F6 but I just want
to show you what happens if Knight
captures on E3 so okay it's a piece
sacrifice yes but you get to play C5
challenge the Knight and once the Knight
moves okay you you cannot play D5 right
away because B4 is coming and you want
to avoid that so you have to prepare it
with A5 and once let's say Rook a to C1
is play now you play Pawn to D5 and now
white will make a move Pawn to D4 and
this massive Pawn Center is definitely
worth a piece here so this is one way
Leon could have continued the other one
is just C5 this does not include a pawn
sacrifice H but on the other hand you
don't get that much play with black for
example H captures on G4 you will play C
captures on D4 and after Rook captures
on D4 D5 now and okay uh you you you
have you have a nice Center not as nice
as in the one where you sacrif fight
your piece but you will have to play
something passive like Bishop to E6 uh
to defend your pawn and white will of
course at some point try to get the
bishop into the game via df1 square and
just you know start pushing those pawns
create a pass Pawn uh and so on so not
maybe as exciting as Knight captures on
E3 but Leon played Knight back to F6 and
now we have Queen captures on C6 just a
nice Queen trade captures captures and
now Rook to D7 and okay Rook 8 to C1 and
now bsh Bishop to B7 attacking the
Knight we have Knight to A5 attacking
the bishop and now Pawn to D5 uh Bishop
to F1 this is a beautiful move by AB
Manu as it brings the light Square
Bishop into the game and uh you also
have to watch out for some tactics in
the future because now if you develop
The Rook for example Knight captures on
B7 followed by Bishop captures on A6
maybe not uh right away but you know at
some point we have King F7 Pawn to B4
now we have Rook to G8 preparing Pawn to
G5 and now King to F2 uh we have Pawn to
G5 Pawn to A3 H you also want your uh B4
Pawn defended if you go for something
like Knight captures on B7 Bishop
captures on A6 and then of course you
want the B4 Pawn defended so G captures
on F4 G captures you need your E Pawn to
guard against the D4 Pawn push and now
Rook to G6 and interestingly uh here the
move that we were eyeing all along
Knight captur on B7 is enough to win the
game but it's very very complicated and
you have to look really really really
far I'm just going to show it because
it's super fun uh if Knight captures
Rook captures and Bishop captures point
is that now Knight captures on G4 check
will win the bishop on A6 but it doesn't
matter Rook captures on A6 you will play
G captures on F5 so you are up material
for the moment Rook captures on A3
grabbing one Pawn but now Rook to H1 and
there's really no good way uh to handle
this with with black either you allow
the the white king and pawn to start
marching forward Rook captures H7 is the
immediate threat and if you block this
with King G7 then Rook to C6 comes and
amazingly the B4 Pawn is poisoned if you
capture on B4 uh it's game over Rook to
C7 check now you either go go back and
then you allow the pawn to start
marching forward or you block the pawn
and then you get checkmated Rook H6
check King captures Rook to F7 with
check King to G4 now Rook to G7 check
King F5 and Rook to G5 will be Checkmate
so that's the problem here uh so not
captur on B7 is actually perfectly fine
but Abu plays a more gentlemanly move
the one that does not require you to
calculate so much but it also uh does
require you to play very very precise
Knight to B3 and okay what can leevon
play now he goes for Rook H6 uh okay he
puts pressure on the H3 Pawn so the
bishop cannot be so easily developed uh
Knight to D4 now D F5 Pawn is weak so of
course you have to defend it Rook to H5
and now Rook to C5 putting uh more on um
Black's position now A5 uh A4 A5 B5 all
of those Pawn pushes are coming and abim
Manu will create a pass Pawn on the
queen side Knight to G8 we have Rook D
to C1 doubling up on the C file and now
Knight to E7 we have Pawn to A4 and now
Rook to H6 we have Pawn to A5 Pawn to B5
is also fine we have Pawn to A5 King to
f8 and now Pawn to B5 so the pass Pawn
is now created a captures on B5 we have
Bishop Capt R and Rook D to D6 now uh
trying to hold on to the to the sixth
rank but now Rook to C7 attacking the
bishop on B7 that's undefended so Bishop
to A6 offering a trade and now just
Bishop captures Rook captures and Rook
to B1 the absolute strongest move and he
was in this position on move 45 that
leevon Aran resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here it's a a
terrible terrible uh position plus uh if
you don't capture the A5 Pawn you know
that you're just going to lose the game
so you might as well capture it but then
comes Rook to B8 with check and after
King to F7 then comes Knight captures on
F5 uh or I mean you could play you could
also play Rook captures on E7 it will
also be sufficient for a victory you
will also pick up the Rook here so you
know however you want to play it it's
perfectly fine Knight captures on F5 is
the the most precise and now you're just
going to uh you know Snowball your way
from here Rook to h8 and black is
basically without a move you have some D
for counter play but it is not uh nearly
enough Knight captures on E7 for example
D4 Knight captures on E7 and if D
captures an E3 King uh can capture an E3
and now uh well you're down a piece so
you have to capture it back and if Rook
captures an E7 then just Rook captures
King captures and king captur sorry not
um uh capturing first you capture on H7
and then of course you win the the the
free rook so that's the idea uh but yeah
uh of course uh leevon saw all of this
and after Rook to B1 he resigned as
there really is nothing more to try here
and abanu had a great opportunity in the
last round he played Fabiano corana who
won the tournament and uh he could have
if he got at least a half a point then
it would be interesting in the final
round but as fa won now ABI Manu won
second place or it's a shared second
place between lineer Dominguez Perez
weso and abanu Mishra with Fabby winning
first place and if you're interested Ed
in the other um placement so it's Fab 8
6 and a half Wesley Banu and and
Dominguez Perez then with five and a
half Samuel Sean Hans nean Ray Robson
with five leevon Aran with four and a
half Sam Shanklin and Jeffrey Shong and
with four Andrew tang and Darius SCH uh
so there we have it that is this short
coverage of the US Chess Championship
Fabiano takes it second time in a row
absolutely incredible performance we'll
see if he will be able to repeat it for
the third time I would like to thank
congratulations Dr sh Tucker Berkman
Eddie Indus bullet thriller.com and Chad
Smith for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here uh thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World uh so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your
day